foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
missing more than two miles down coast
guards wide in the search for the sub on
its way to the Titanic
if it's intact it's passengers including
a British billionaire and a father and
son will have around a day and a half of
air left
the search is battling the elements of
the coast of Newfoundland we'll report
from there tonight
plus the president's son pleading guilty
to a court and sparking Fury from Joe
Biden's opponents
the social influencer condemned as toxic
and now charged with rape and human
trafficking
what do we say then king of German so I
say your majesty
[Music]
the man who would be king we speak to
one of the figureheads of Germany's far
right as the country's Security Services
warned their numbers are growing
Picture Perfect the Royal seal of
approval for a reopened National
Portrait Gallery
and will take a first look at tomorrow's
front pages in our press preview from 10
30.
[Music]
a very good evening the search for the
missing submersible which was on its way
to the wreck of the Titanic has already
covered an area nearly the size of Wales
there is no sign yet though of the Titan
the U.S Coast Guard says it's five
passengers if the sub is intact would
have around 36 hours of oxygen left by
now
the eight-day Expedition now missing at
Sea set off from Newfoundland on
Canada's East Coast it traveled from
there to the Titanic site which is just
under 400 miles off the coast
the Canadian research Icebreaker polar
Prince which was supporting the Titan
reportedly lost contact with the vessel
about an hour and 45 minutes after it
submerged our International
correspondent John Sparks reports now
from Newfoundland
summer hasn't troubled the North
Atlantic this year the seas are rough
and visibility low to non-existent
it's a bad time to launch an
international search and rescue mission
crew members of the submersible Titan
left this port just a few days ago now
the operation to save them will be based
from the same facility
and the leader of Newfoundland said it
won't be easy we've had one of the worst
Springs in on record the worst spring
since 1943 which of course is is bad
enough being on land it's absolutely
terrible being 600 kilometers off our
Shores we're talking you know 12 foot
waves a heavy fog very difficult search
and rescue conditions these pictures of
the submersible were taken moments
before it began its descent
an experimental vessel made from carbon
fiber and titanium the owner said it
could monitor the strength of its Hull
in real time one hour and 45 minutes
later the support team lost contact
and at a press conference in Boston the
U.S Coast Guard said the vessel has
still not been located good afternoon
these search efforts have focused on
both surface
with C-130 aircraft searching by sight
and with radar and subsurface with P3
aircraft we're able to drop and monitor
sonar buoys
to date those search efforts have not
yielded any results
the names of all five crew members on
the Titan are now known
British Adventurer Hamish Harding is
joined by the owner of the submersible
Stockton Rush
prominent Pakistani businessman shazada
diode and his son Suleiman are also on
board both hold British citizenship
and we understand French explorer Paul
orri najalay of referred to as Mr
Titanic is also on the vessel a close
friend said he knew the risks but we
knew this was going to happen at some
point along the way
and uh Newt darn well it would and we
knew all the difficulties there would be
about how do you recover from that if
the sub is stuck on a shipwreck if they
lose batteries if they're caught on the
bottom some other way uh and nothing was
done about it the weighty responsibility
of a deep sea rescue now belongs to the
governments of two Nations and a host of
private actors
they've seen tragedy on the high seas on
this island before and they've mounted
complex rescue efforts from here as well
but no one not the Americans not the
Canadians have been involved in an
operation like this not at these
distances and not at these depths
the premier and the people of this
province have offered their prayers and
they know that time is running out John
Sparks Sky News Saint John's
Newfoundland
while the Titan submersible made
multiple Dives to the wreck of the
Titanic in the last two years it has a
system which is supposed to detect early
any breach of its Hull under the
pressure two miles down skies Matthew
Thompson has this now on the subs design
this is the Titan submersible it's 6.7
meters or 22 feet long its Hull is made
out of carbon fiber and titanium and it
weighs nearly 10 and a half tons about
the same as six cars which according to
its operator Ocean Gate means it's
lighter and cheaper to run than any
other deep water sub Titan is powered by
four electric thrusters which allow it
to travel at a top speed of three knots
or 3.4 miles per hour and it's able to
dive to depth of 4 000 meters roughly 13
000 feet Ocean Gate says it would take
two hours to dive the roughly 3 800
meters to where Titanic lies
the vessel is designed to take five
people with enough oxygen for around 96
hours a porthole window at one end lets
passengers peer out Into the Depths and
large screens display various data from
cameras and scanners that are mounted on
the outside and it also has a system for
monitoring the vessel's hull in real
time which means it's possible to
analyze how the hull is coping under the
extreme pressure now in theory that
should give the pilot enough warning of
any problems to safely return to the
surface in plenty of time
the search for the missing craft is
focused in the Atlantic Ocean about 370
miles to the south of Newfoundland in
Canada and let's be clear this is an
incredibly remote part of the ocean it's
said to have an undulating seabed at a
depth of nearly 13 000 feet but the
Titanic wreck lying in a trench and
that's so deep that Britain's highest
mountain Ben Nevis would fit in nearly
three times so what are the conditions
like at such depths a former Royal Navy
rear Admiral gave us his assessment
the pressure down at that level is about
two tons per square inch whereas of
course at the surface it's just one
atmosphere so you've got that to contend
with so the pressure Hull has to
withstand that sort of weight if you
like secondly it's very cold and if they
don't have any electricity it's dark as
well so these are Extreme Survival
conditions but the critical thing is
that the pressure Hull withstands that
pressure
now this time lapse shows marine traffic
in the hours after the sub went missing
you can see that a number of ships start
to move to the area where it disappeared
and according to Ocean Gate the Titan
made successful expeditions to the
Titanic wreckage in both 2021 and 2022
and it's undergone more than 50 test
Dives including the company says to a
depth of nearly 4 000 meters
Matthew Thompson there and John Sparks
joins us from Newfoundland tonight good
evening to you John this complex search
operation continues and its coordination
is being moved to where you are
yeah that's right Sally I think one of
the really difficult things uh here is
that no one country or military or Coast
Guard no one a private outfit private
company have all the skills and the
experience or all the specialist
equipment that they need to perform a
rescue operation like this they have to
work together that's really complicated
but they do have to work together and
they have to do it quickly because time
really has become the most precious
commodity here we heard from the U.S
Coast Guard this afternoon they said the
oxygen and energy systems on the
submersible Titan they had about 40
hours left that's probably 36 hours
about a day and a half by my Reckoning
so The Rescuers both have to reach this
craft if it is structurally sound they
have to reach it and then perform a
rescue as well and time truly is running
out at this stage
certainly it is a race against the clock
John thanks very much
now you might expect President Biden's
political opponents to be excoriating
over his son's guilty plea to tax and
Firearms charges in court today they
were but only over what former president
Trump called a mere traffic ticket he
and other Republicans have called for
Hunter Biden and his father to be
investigated for what they allege is
corruption his parents simply said
tonight they loved him and would support
him as he rebuilt his life from
Washington our U.S correspondent James
Matthews has more
he's not the Biden front man but in the
background he looms large and my
youngest son Hunter Biden Stand Up Guys
I'm proud of you
Hunter Biden is a treasured son
politically he troubles his father
highly publicized criminal inquiries
have now crystallized into two guilty
please
they relate to two separate charges of
failing to pay his taxis a deal has been
reached on a third charge of wrongfully
possessing a firearm having failed to
declare that he was a drug user
Hunter Biden should Escape jail his
father didn't dodge accusations of bias
from Donald Trump himself facing
prosecution there was this wow the
corrupt Biden Department of Justice just
cleared up hundreds of years of criminal
liability by giving Hunter Biden a mere
traffic ticket our system is broken
claims of corruption echoed through
Republican ranks because the question is
is it equal justice so you have one
leading opponent of the current
president that is now indicted they're
supposed to do jail time have a
president's son that the investigation
went on for a very long time that now
has to do no jail time
Hunter Biden is the youngest son of the
current U.S president
he's put his crimes down to struggles
with drug use following the death of his
older brother bull calling it a period
of turmoil and addiction
in the same period he handed his laptop
to a repairman in Delaware but he didn't
return to collect it the repairman says
alongside self-made pornography it
contained evidence that Hunter Biden
used his father's influence in foreign
business dealings
I'm very proud of my son said the father
as the news broke legally it marks the
end of a chapter in the story
politically it remains an open book
James Matthews Sky News in Washington
the social media influencer Andrew Tate
is already facing allegations of rape
here in the UK now prosecutors
investigating him in Romania have
charged him with rape human trafficking
and forming a criminal gang to exploit
women he denies both the British and
Romanian allegations our Europe
correspondent Adam Parsons reports
six months after he was first arrested
Andrew Tate knows his fate now charged
with some of the most serious crimes
imaginable rape human trafficking and
organized crime
Tate is under house arrest at his home a
converted industrial unit in the suburbs
of Bucharest his response to the charges
came through social media first saying
I'm sure this case has absolutely
nothing to do with stealing my wealth
and then telling nearly 7 million
Twitter followers this isn't about
whether you like me or not this is about
all of us today it's me tomorrow it's
you nobody is safe from these lies
chicks just stuck in a house sitting
there bored completely in love with me
and of course they don't go out they're
not allowed out Tate's profile is built
on online content that's targeted at
teenage boys and young men critics claim
it's misogynistic violent and dangerous
it's alleged that he and his brother
Tristan used physical and mental
intimidation to force women into
producing pornographic content
it's why they allege victims and those
who've worked with them insist that
these women are victims of violence
trafficking and coercion sex trafficking
is not always someone being locked in
Chains and held in a dungeon quite
typically the most common form of uh
coercion that traffickers use is
psychological manipulation so someone
can go to a grocery store or even look
like they're smiling in a video but be
being sex trafficked it's now up to the
Romanian courts to decide if and when
this trial will take place
Andrew Tate has molded himself into a
Brash Unapologetic celebrity a court
will decide if he's actually a violent
Criminal
Adam Parsons Sky News
austerity wasn't to blame for the poor
response to the covid crisis in the UK
its architect told the covert inquiry
today instead it had created the fiscal
space to address it said former
Chancellor George Osborne just like his
ex-boss David Cameron he defended the
then government's actions as our
correspondent Sadia Chaudhary reports
please I would make one point that was
also we also just let me ask my question
a fiery exchange between the former
Chancellor of the exchequer and the
covid inquiry lawyer if someone had said
it was George Osborne's turn today to
defend his work and not just defend he
took credit for helping us survive the
pandemic
from the furlough scheme to avoiding a
banking crisis to funding the vaccine
program
in 2020 it turned out to be fairly easy
and Rapid to be able to put those
support systems in place through the
program we pursued as a government we
created the fiscal space so we could end
up spending 370 billion pounds to help
people deal with all the adverse effects
that the lockdown introduced
if Mr Osborne was looking for a thank
you this isn't the place the covid
inquiry is trying to establish whether
his treasury had planned for a pandemic
their witness today told them in no
uncertain terms it hadn't no one I'm
aware of anywhere in the Western World
maybe anywhere else anywhere in the
world said you know what governments
should prepare for they should prepare
for a Converse pandemic that will
require us to lock down the entire
economy for months on end obviously if
someone had said that
then there would be a legitimate
question which is why are you preparing
for it but I'm unfortunately no one did
like his boss the day before Mr Osborne
left the inquiry refusing to accept any
blame he'd been forced to defend his
austerity regime because earlier this
week there'd been suggestions that he
and David Cameron had left the Health
Service depleted that came from the
doctors Union the trades Union Congress
and some bereaved family members
now it's up to the inquiry chair to say
whether she agrees Sadia Chaudhary Sky
News at the covid inquiry in London
one claims that Russia is Germany's
natural partner not enemy another calls
himself the king of the country both are
faces of the German far right who've
spoken to Sky News Germany's domestic
intelligence agency says the country's
right-wing extremism is the greatest
greatest threat to democracy there with
nearly 40 000 active members our Europe
correspondent Siobhan Robbins reports
from Wittenberg in a self-proclaimed
Kingdom of Germany
[Applause]
many an old threat with a changing face
the far right has been named the biggest
danger to democracy here
while some extreme groups are easy to
recognize two hours outside Berlin a
less well-known Community is also being
monitored by the authorities this is the
headquarters of the self-proclaimed
Kingdom of Germany how do I
address you and today I'm meeting their
self-appointed King what do we say then
king of Germany so I say your majesty
the authorities list them as extremists
who want to take control of Germany and
overthrow the current system so you've
got own driving license own identity
card own passport yes own currency own
own
the German intelligence agencies class
the kingdom as part of a growing rice
Burger movement 23
000 people who reject the legitimacy of
the post-war German state
in December 25 people were arrested for
plotting to storm the Parliament and
overthrow the government
while King Peter wants change he says
his group would never use violence
the rice Burger coup plot failed but
more than 38 000 people across Germany
are now classified as right-wing
extremists a major concern for the
authorities it was to be a far fewer
democratically we were attacked Suleiman
Malik received death threats from the
far right while trying to build his
mosque one day he arrived to find this
this is a pig head and this is what I
found here when I came pork scattered
around the planned place of worship do
you think there would be a lot of
support if there was a coup that
installed a right-wing government yes
there will be you think there is yes
there will be there is why because they
see that this is the solution
's particularly worried about the
rocketing popularity of the afd a
far-right party in Parliament that's
also on the watch list are you divisive
are you dangerous
but left-wing opponents say Germany is
being split into history has shown the
terror Unleashed by an uncontrolled far
right here some fear amid growing
discontent extremism could dominate
again Siobhan Robbins Sky News Germany
the former first minister of Scotland
Nicholas sturgeon has returned to
Hollywood for the first time since being
arrested by police investigating the
smp's finances she's still resisting
calls to stand down and as an MSP
insisting she has done nothing wrong
would it be the best thing for you to
temporarily step back as some of your
colleagues have suggested I search my
soul in these questions what that would
do
be to compromise my ability and my right
to assert the position that I hold
absolutely which is that I have done
nothing wrong
the man accused of murdering three
people and attempting to kill three
others in Nottingham will go on trial in
January Baldo calacani appeared at
Nottingham Crown Court today charged
with murdering 19 year old students
Barnaby Weber and Grace O'Malley Kumar
and 65 year old school caretaker Ian
Coates and the attempted murders of
three pedestrians
and the judge hearing the phone hacking
case brought against mirror group
newspapers has questioned if several
people including former editor Piers
Morgan could and should have given some
evidence in court a former mirror
journalist this week told the court Mr
Morgan had explained how to hack a phone
now they call England's new aggressive
style of cricket baz all after the
team's combative coach but despite an
enthralling first ashes match it did
lead to defeat today as Australia won
with two wickets to spare neither the
fans nor players were downbeat though as
our correspondent inzaman Rasheed
reports from edgebastin tirelessly day
five of the first Ash's test began with
nothing other than rain but once the
covers were removed and the players
emerged there was no greater reminder as
to why test match cricket is still very
much alive
just after half an hour an early
breakthrough
after T England's Target of five wickets
soon became four
oh he's got him
however Australia stood firm 200 up and
moving closer to that winning total
but for big moments you need big players
[Applause]
and they don't come much bigger than Ben
Stokes
and Cummins had other ideas hunting down
the target with these Lusty blows
up and over again aggression with Nathan
lime the pair held their nerve pressure
soaked up until the very end a win with
two wickets to spare will come back for
two oh
and Australia are home
the England Captain disappointed but
undaunted losing hurts regardless of
what you've done winning is always a
great feeling and but you know our loss
is a loss but you know we're going to
continue keep coming at Australia in the
way that we did you can have shorter
formats of the game you can enjoy
franchise Cricket across the globe but
it's clear after five exhilarating days
test match cricket is alive and kicking
the question is is bazball saving this
game
love it don't care that we lost I love
the way the games go like very happy
with everything much more exciting to
watch it's much more enjoyable to be a
fan to see us play that way it's
brilliant it's good to see that
aggressiveness and uh yeah it's good to
see them back themselves and have that
confidence
today wasn't England's day but there
were moments of magic they'll now look
to Lords in a week's time with hopes to
level this series which has already
given so much into man Rashid Sky News
Edge Boston
finally some of the most photographed
people in the country were part of the
celebrations today as the home of
portraiture the National Portrait
Gallery reopened visitors will now be
able to see some of Sir Paul McCartney's
own photos of the early Beatles as well
as carved brass images of women created
by Tracy Emin it has Royal approval too
as our arts and entertainment
correspondent Katie Spencer reports and
we should warn you this report contains
flashy images
only fitting perhaps that among the
first to check out the National Portrait
gallery's multi-million pound facelift
one of the most recognizable faces in
Britain
after three years closed for a top to
bottom refurbishment it's Royal Patron
the Princess of Wales not only invited
to look at one or two of its new
acquisitions but being shown the door
not figuratively literally it's
jaw-dropping designed by renowned artist
Tracy Emin her 45 carved brass panels an
attempt to represent Every Woman
throughout time counterbalancing the
prominent male figures who for over a
century have dominated the building's
facade
it communicates a new message to our
audiences and our visitors that this is
a gallery for everyone people of all
backgrounds ages nationalities
adding to the gallery's star-studded
comeback and meet and greet for the
princess with Sir Paul McCartney not
demonstrating his singing skills but his
photography having Unearthed these gems
images he thought he'd lost will be on
show until the Autumn tracking his time
in the Beatles just as the band were
taking off
Grace and Perry Among the Stars out for
a special party celebrating the
gallery's reopening its return coming at
a time when images of individuals are
now more abundant than at any other
point in our history is it necessary
institution because we're all yeah
fascinated by identity now you know
we're riveted by it and the whole and
everybody's taking picture themselves
and building their kind of online
profile
and so a place like this it will respond
to that desire for everybody to be a
unique individual
proving there's more to portraiture than
just a pretty face Katie Spencer Sky
News
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
papers in the Press preview including
this story on the front of the Guardian
which says mortgage Time Bomb bailout
calls split Tories we'll definitely be
talking about that and tonight we're
joined by the journalist and broadcaster
Jenny cleeman and the mail on Sundays
acting Deputy political editor Claire
Ellicott
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is Sky News in just a moment the
Press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive but first
are top stories
the search has been expanded for the
submersible that went missing near the
wreck of the Titanic it's thought to
have just over 35 hours of oxygen left
President Biden's son Hunter is likely
to avoid a prison sentence after
striking a deal with prosecutors over
tax and Firearms charges
and the former Chancellor George Osborne
has told the covert inquiry austerity
made Britain better able to cope with
the pandemic
[Music]
hello there it's good to have you with
us you're watching the Press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive
it's time to see what's making the
headlines let's have a look at the front
page of the Daily Mail their headline 24
hours to save them unsurprisingly that
story is leading many of the front pages
tomorrow
the Metro also leading with the last
photo of the submersible before its
Journey to the wreck
the sun interviews a man who says he was
booked to travel on the missing vessel
meanwhile the daily Stars there's the
missing submersible is steered by a 42
pound video game controller
the chancellors summoned banks for
mortgage talks but rules out Aid to
homeowners that's on tomorrow's front
page of the financial times
the eye goes further leading with a
warning that the Tories face a UK
mortgage time bomb
while the guardian leads with mortgage
Time Bomb bailout calls split tories
the covert pandemic damaged a generation
of young people that's on the front of
the Daily Telegraph
and reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you're
watching us
and we're joined tonight by journalist
and broadcaster Jenny cleeman and the
mail on Sunday's acting Deputy political
editor Claire Ellicott great to have you
both with us thanks so much uh for
joining us uh Jenny let's kick off with
the front page of the Metro like many of
tomorrow's papers leading on uh the
missing sub at their headline Titanic
sub last photo and focusing very much on
this Race Against Time in terms of the
amount of oxygen they're estimating the
team have left
yes and also the fact that more details
are emerging about the five people
believed to be inside uh this
submersible uh three britons one aged
just 19. uh but three of them there's a
father and son that's the 19 year old is
the son three of them are thought to be
very experienced deep sea adventurers
um this has shown a light on a very
expensive kind of adventuring it's sort
of disaster tourism that may have turned
into a disaster itself or at least uh
wrecked tourism uh they paid 200 000
pounds of Passenger they've gone down or
tried to go down 3 800 meters that's as
as low as the ounce as High
um Extraordinary People in terms of
wealth but also willingness to to take
on a really serious Adventure
um I guess so those details have been
emerging today and also the fact that
other people who have uh been on the
Titan this uh submarine to go down to
see the Titanic have been talking about
how they uh knew of the risks or perhaps
suspected there were great risks and had
to sign waivers going down it is 48
hours since it lost contact and we found
out today from the U.S Coast Guard that
um there are around 40 hours of
breathable air left inside there which
means that uh by sort of Thursday
morning our time uh the air is going to
run out so it is a Race Against Time and
it is a search and rescue mission both
parts of that are incredibly difficult
searching an area as large as Wales and
trying to rescue people that far uh deep
down so there is a kind of
you know incredible symmetry about this
it's like a disaster movie uh of a
famous historical
um disaster is there going to be another
massive loss of life here
um it's rare for things to go wrong on
submersible so lots of questions are
being asked in the papers but for now we
just have no idea what's going on uh
aboard the submarine yeah Claire The
Daily Mail I'm also leading with this
story tomorrow morning I was saying to
someone today it really reminds me of of
the coverage of the young football team
in Thailand who are trapped in that cave
and the whole world was rooting for them
but this time it does seem to be far
more challenging because there's just
absolutely no idea where they are and of
course there's a huge expanse that they
have to search
I mean this is truly the stuff of
nightmares there's five people trapped
in this tiny object it's only 22 foot
long I think and they are thousands
probably thousands of meters Under the
Sea surface
um it's absolutely impossible to search
the sea
um you know they talk about the surface
of the Moon being better explored than
some of the depths of the ocean it
absolutely is just an impossible task
and the Coast Guard and all of the other
agencies involved are truly in a Race
Against Time there are 40 hours of air
day estimate left in this submarine um
it's unimaginable what the people in
there and are going through it's it's
just and for their families as well and
it's it's a fact that you know diving is
a dangerous Endeavor they've gone down I
think it's 13 000 Feet Under the Sea the
Titanic is that the Titanic wreck is
located and they were in really
difficult weather conditions and before
they did the dive and you know they we
just don't know where they are the US
Coast Guard is there they've had no luck
so far they've searched thousands and
thousands of feet of the ocean and we
see with um planes with with boats and
also I think they've got underwater
drones looking for these people but it
is a really really difficult task and it
is a real Race Against Time and um it
must be just unimaginable what what
their families are going through at the
moment
um it truly is you know a real real
Reckoning absolutely I was I was
speaking to one of the experts we've
been interviewing earlier and I said you
know it's it's a needle in a haystack
situation and he said it would be easier
to find a needle in a haystack it really
doesn't bear thinking about but let's
hold our breath there's still time and
there's still hope let's move on to one
of the other main stories leading some
of the papers uh tomorrow Jenny the
front page of the financial times very
much focusing on this uh concern over
people's mortgages uh one Tory MP
calling it a mortgage bomb about to go
off
yeah a mortgage Time Bomb about to go
off that was that was Jake Berry of uh
of uh one of the northern uh research
group red wall uh seats
um Martin Lewis the the big money saving
expert has also used this phrase
mortgage time but I'm about to go off it
is really worrying for people and there
are millions of people I'm one of them
uh who are facing the end of their
mortgage deals and uh seeing a huge jump
in interest rates tomorrow we are going
to see the latest set of inflation
figures and inflation is expected to be
down but not very much not by very much
we have um
still the most stubborn inflation and
the highest level relation of all the G7
countries and uh Jeremy Hunt says he
cannot provide assistance to people who
have mortgages because that would make
inflation worse but he's under pressure
from from his fellow MPS to do so I mean
this kind of thing is is a real uh you
know vote winner or rather it affects
people at The Ballot Box and not just
people who have mortgages renters are
facing an enormous squeeze rents are
going up apparently more renters are
paying a greater proportion of of their
wage on rent than they have done for for
many years simply because mortgage rates
are so high and interest rates are of
course expected to go up yet again this
year to the highest levels since 2008 so
it is frightening times for a lot of
people and what's really worrying is
that things don't seem to be getting
better Jeremy Hunt has said that he's
going to talk to Banks and banks are
going to help uh lenders on a uh they're
going to help people with mortgages on a
Case by case basis help people out if
they can't pay but it's not so much a
question of not being able to pay there
are a lot of people who will just about
manage to pay but they are not going to
be able to save any money spend any any
money in it as we know uh interest rates
are going up and they're going up on
mortgages but we're not feeling them so
much on our savings so um Bleak times
ahead I would say
yeah it is rather bleed it's hot it's
hard to dress this up uh isn't it Claire
at the front page of the Guardian also
leading with this line of mortgage uh
time bomb and we could of course see
interest rates go up again on Thursday
uh and I I find it quite interesting to
read earlier that 400 000 people are
gonna see their current uh mortgage
deals end between July and September
yes this is a real worry for the Tories
we're going into an election next year
so Jeremy Hunt is under real pressure to
do something as the chancellor but the
facts are that if you start pumping
money into into the system you you will
in theory trigger more inflation which
is one of the reasons why costs are so
high at the moment anyway so they're in
a really difficult bind and they're
coming out of real pressure from a lot
of their MPS Jake Berry as we just
mentioned
um he's he's one of the he's from a red
Aussie in the northern research group of
Victoria MPS but in actual fact I think
the some of the blue walls some of the
Tories kind of more traditional
supporters down south are going to be
really really hard hit by this and um
the rates are going up a lot you know
these are real noticeable differences
for most homeowners and um you know it's
not just affecting people at the lower
end of the scale it's affecting people
in the middle classes who may find that
their mortgage is beyond what they can
afford to pay and the Specter of
negative equity and you know people
having to fall on their loans is is a
real worry so this is I think why Jeremy
Hunt has called in the bank
um I think on Friday to have to speak to
them about what possibly they can do but
the realities are that there aren't many
levers at his control or even at the
bank's control because this problem is
um ingrained and we've got sluggish
growth you know there's there's high
levels of inflation they're persistent
then they seem to be coming down despite
as being one of Russia students real
priorities and um the facts are that
they're these costs are being passed
onto homeowners which are you know the
key group of Voters that toys need to
keep happy and it's really looking
perilous for the year ahead yeah
certainly Jenny's it's so worrying for
so many people who are already
struggling to make ends meet and as
Claire was saying there you know Jeremy
Hunt is meeting with lenders on Friday
but the government has already said that
they're not going to intervene
financially
yeah I mean there's there's only so much
that that lenders can do as I said
before they can help with people who are
in Desperate circumstances by helping
them out with affecting their their
credit repeating but there's nothing
really they can do and you know Claire
mentions a general election coming up in
2024. there are many by-elections coming
up within a few months and in fact um
the shadow Chancellor Rachel Reeves made
the point today quite clever really she
she found out she did some number
crunching found out that 10 100
households in uh Boris Johnson's old
seat of Oxbridge uh are going to be
facing average mortgage costs that are
an extra 2 700 pounds a year people
think about this stuff uh because
obviously the labor party are spinning
this as being a direct consequence of
Liz truss's mini budget of course uh the
conservatives would like to say that
it's a consequence of the war in in
Ukraine economic factors beyond their
control but I think most people feel
that this is an avoidable crisis that
this comes out of mistake thanks to the
conservatives have made and they have
lost their reputation for financial
competence Jeremy Hunt is trying to claw
that back but this is something that
they need to address and not just before
the next general election they need to
address it now before all of these
by-elections
um Claire let's just squeeze in another
story before the break front page of the
financial times is also covering uh this
story of Hunter Biden Joe Biden's son
who's been charged with federal crimes
it's really interesting isn't it because
this is a story that's been followed
very closely for a long time now in the
U.S but hasn't really cut through here
in the UK in the same way
yes I mean hunter Biden has been a way
of attacking Joe Biden since he became
the president he's the sort of weak Link
in the president's camp and we've all
seen those photos of him he's you know
he's he's in the path had addictions
he's um you know admitted to all sorts
of things and we've now seen these new
charges and the facts are that he you
know he is the convenience to beat Joe
Biden with and you know the president
sort of enemies in the Republican Camp
will be making as much as they can of
this
um but you know Joe this is a member of
Joe Biden's family you know there's not
really
um you know there's not much he can do
about it it's it's it's just a sort of
ongoing worry for the president but
um you know it remains to be seeing what
will happen as a result of this but it
does seem like everyone in the US in the
future presidential election system
rather embroiled in the series of court
cases at the moment and um you know
it'll be very interesting to run up to
the election what what happens there
yeah it's contagious it's isn't it and
certainly um Jenny I mean it was to be
expected Donald Trump came out speaking
very critically calling this a mere
traffic ticket for Hunter Biden today
but but some comparing his situation
with with the legal challenges facing
Donald Trump saying he should also just
accept some charges and avoid going to
trial
well this this massively plays into
Donald Trump's hands because he can say
that the Department of Justice is is on
Biden's side and is uh is letting his
son off uh with a wrap on the knuckles
uh you know Hunter Biden is a private
individual and Donald Trump he faced
these federal charges for things that he
directly
um had done but nonetheless this this
very much plays into how Donald Trump
wants to spin things he has been going
on about Hunter Biden and his laptop for
many many years Hunter Biden has had
troubles for many years too troubles uh
with addiction he's been struggling for
a very long time but he is not running
to be president like Donald Trump is or
uh his dad is running for for
re-election What's significant about
this is the narrative that allows Donald
Trump to uh to spin about a corrupt
system uh designed to be unfair to him
and this is something that will play
really well I think with Donald Trump
supporters okay Jenny Claire we'll give
you a bit of a breather see you in just
a moment thank you very much so much do
stay with us we'll have more of our
press preview next including this on the
front of the telegraph at their headline
lockdown damaged a generation it says X
CMO that's the former Chief medical
officer we'll be speaking about that
after this short break
[Music]
thank you
yeah well this is the Expedition it's
frightening that it can even happen the
ice is disappearing when the first
person made it all the way through the
Northwest Passage over 120 years ago it
took him you know three or four years
because he would get frozen in the ice
he'd get stuck there and then he'd have
uh 11 months stuck there two weeks
making forward progress 11 months stuck
there again and so on whereas fast
forward 120 years and we have three to
four months to make it all the way 2 000
Miles because the ice is just making its
way back more and more every year well
I'm starting in a place called Baylor
Island and finishing tuktayak took at
the other end of the Northwest Passage
and it's 2000 miles in between I'm
excited about doing this journey but
it's only facilitated by global warming
and as a result I feel this great you
know responsibility to be a Storyteller
about what is happening up there and why
it's important to us back here well you
know sometimes climate change is so big
and so abstract that it can be difficult
for people to process and therefore make
changes in their own life but if there's
something that's so tangible you know
this place would have been frozen
a hundred years ago 10 years ago then
it's easier for people to grasp and
grasp
urgency building this Foundation is a
charity that helps people get Outdoors
for their mental health and have therapy
through their experiences in nature and
for me my mental health really suffered
after I attempted to grow the Atlantic
twice and both times failed I really
felt worthless and pathetic and overcome
with these feelings of of failure and
for me a big Journey back to uh getting
into a position to take on an expedition
like this was getting back into nature
setting myself challenges and for me
I've been very privileged my whole life
it's been very easy for me to get into
nature I've had role models and easy
access but the Wilderness Foundation
helps people from backgrounds who don't
necessarily have that sort of easy
access to have the same opportunities
that maybe I took for granted as a kid
I've been kayaking a lot obviously but
maybe not as much as people would expect
you know I've been given a lot of advice
about maybe not taking on huge huge
kayaks and burning myself out before I
start so I've been doing a lot of weight
training a lot of yoga but the big thing
for me is getting my skill level of
kayaking up you know kayaking requires a
lot of skill compared to something like
ocean rowing you know got to stay
upright be able to deal with breaking
waves land in Surf to be safe and to be
fast
foreign
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview it's good to have you with us
and with me uh this evening it's Jenny
Cleveland and Claire Ellicott uh kicking
off again on some of the front pages and
the stories in tomorrow's newspapers um
Claire Let's uh let's speak about what's
on the front page of the Daily Telegraph
if I may uh the covert inquiry a really
emotional testimony uh today from the
former Chief medical officer describing
lockdown as damaging a generation
yeah so this is um Sally Davies the
former Chief medical officer she's been
giving evidence to the covert inquiry
and what she said is that lockdown was
really damaging for a generation of
children and for everyone else that was
involved as well now we all know how
um you know how difficult it was for the
country for the for the government to
put the country into lockdown and um the
real kind of um you know kind of
consequences of this are only really
being seen now you have so many children
who Miss so much schooling and people at
University who Miss schooling people at
work who just didn't get you know the
opportunities they should have done and
do you know Miss the chances to
socialize with their colleagues and to
have a like well-rounded life and you
know it's been a really really difficult
time for so so many people and um the
real and you know the the chief former
Chief medical officer really emphasized
that the facts are that you know
lockdown wasn't very good for the
country and um especially not children
at school who weren't able to go to
lessons we've seen you know the
government's tried to put in place some
catch-up lessons but it just hasn't had
the effect that it should have done and
you know they've not been able to do the
same to do to just have the same
opportunities they would have done and
it's really been difficult for a whole
generation of people and um you know the
facts are that the covert is over now
but we are still seeing the lasting
effects of many of those decisions that
were made at the time Jenny I saw you
shaking your head uh at moments there
I'll let you jump in with with whatever
you want to say
yes of course no doubt kovid was very
damaging and it was perhaps most
damaging for for young people who are
least at risk of covid but but I think
Dame Sally Davis was not was not saying
that lockdown shouldn't have happened
because at the time we didn't have a
vaccine and we didn't have any
alternatives and I think the Daily
Telegraph is is very anti-lockdown has
certainly shown itself to be so over the
past few months or so with it with its
disclosure of of lots of things to do
with Matt Hancock's what's that it has
it has an agenda I'm a mother myself I
saw my uh children denied so many
important years of their of their lives
at school
um but you know what was the alternative
that we let a lot of people die I mean
one of the things that Dame Sally said
today was that nobody thought about
lockdowns but that's because they were
Unthinkable at the time I mean nobody
ever considered that in a democratic
country that the state could order
people to stay at home but at the time
we did not know about covid we did not
know about the risk we didn't know who
was at risk and it was the only option
that we had so it's incredibly sad that
people have have been so badly affected
by lockdown and yes a generation has
been harmed but what was the alternative
that we simply uh allowed hundreds of
thousands of people to die that's even
more Unthinkable I would say and kind of
just a final thought from you it was
interesting we heard from um George
Osborne as well who defended austerity
today
Claire can you hear me okay
sorry yes and so children yes the former
Chancellor he um he put in place a
number of um people in place a number of
of you know policies that meant that
that you know there were some of the
services that were available to people
didn't get the same sort of funding that
they had done in the park he's been
blamed obviously for not being prepared
for the pandemic as a result of that
um he's obviously defended himself and
said that you know this wasn't to blame
but so there are some members of the
conservative government have in the past
said that you know there wasn't there
wasn't the things in place to
um enable us to cope with this pandemic
in the same way that uh in the way that
we should have done and um you know we
saw there was a lack of PPE there was a
lack of sort of integral planning which
meant that it was really difficult to
put those Supply chains in place when we
needed them and um you know it was a
real struggle to sort of get the country
through this and we saw time and again
that you know there were contract handed
out to people who weren't deserving of
them they there was so much taxpayers
money wasted and it was a real real
error on the part of some of those who
planned it
um in making sure that the country had
what it needed okay Claire Jenny thanks
so much we'll see you again next hour